hi I'm Eric Voss and we now have a new
look at the Justice League movie coming
out this November and from what we've
seen in this trailer and the footage
released at Comic Con last summer
apparently Aquaman ain't no joke like no
offense to the old school blonde Aquaman
but I feel like he would have Jason
Momoa Aquaman action figures and yeah
this trailer was pretty great and it
included some miserable details that
could be giving us a clear picture of
what kind of movie Justice League is
gonna be and before I break it all down
real quick this video is sponsored by
your friends at movement which is
offering an awesome deal that I'm gonna
tell you about later on but let's get
started
yeah
we have to be ready
you me the others
does the tech coming from far away
so this trailer starts off with these
awesome geo porn shots of Iceland with
Bruce Wayne deciding that the best way
to travel icy mountain terrain is on
horseback
sure now say what you will about zack
snyder in his whole direction of the DC
Cinematic Universe but the guy has an
eye for epic visuals that are really fun
to interpret meaning atom for example
Batman on horseback is such a striking
image like Batman is better known as a
wealthy urban knight who relies on his
intelligence and combat skills and
technological resources so to see him
giddy up like this is such a
naturalistic turn for the character and
Zack Snyder has said that he modeled the
team assembly concept of Justice League
on classic films like Seven Samurai and
the western version of that film The
Magnificent Seven and in both movies
ragtag groups of Fighters come together
to defeat a larger threat so put in
Bruce on horse here might be in no Maj
to those films but also this black horse
could be a reference to the Bible in the
book of Revelation there are 4 Horsemen
of the Apocalypse
and the black horse and rider are
associated with the image of a scale
which in some interpretations means this
rider is the bringer of justice and
considering apocalypse is also the name
of the home planet of Darkseid and his
parademon army I feel like this justice
associated black dressed rider could be
more than a coincidence and this may
just be me but I feel like these shots
of horses and snow flurries were also
inspired by the Game of Thrones
aesthetic like Bruce is kind of like a
brother of the Nights Watch warning that
winter is coming but then again maybe
only think that it gets called Drogo's
in this movie and in case we were
wondering this location is a real-life
herring factory in juvik Iceland think
I'm saying that right it was a small
fishing town where a herring were stored
in process and before I move on Bruce's
line about being ready for an attack
coming from far away echoes the
conversation he had with Diana at the
end of Batman vs Superman help me find
the others like you perhaps they don't
want to be found
no fight so yeah it looks like Justice
League is picking up right up where
Batman vs Superman left off okay let's
move on it's already here the others
where are they so in this section we
hear Diana's ominous response that
faraway threat is actually already here
on earth she's of course referring to
mother boxes that was the device that we
saw briefly in Batman vs Superman when
dr. Silas stone used one while
experimenting on his son Victor stone
cyborg and we went into the backstory of
mother boxes in our first trailer
breakdown but basically there are three
mother boxes on earth and Darkseid and
this boy Steppenwolf are looking for
them and one is apparently with dr.
stone while another is buried in the
ground unless that's the same one
leaving the remaining one or maybe two
to be with the Amazons or the Atlanteans
most likely anyway this is interesting
because in Batman vs Superman
I assume that the mother box technology
reassembled itself as cyborgs parts and
that cyborg as an entity would be kind
of a mother box himself sought by
Darkseid the way that vision is kind of
an infinity stone himself sought by
Thanos and the MCU and by the way if I
ever bring up parallels between the DCU
and other superhero movie universes I'm
not saying one is better or ripping off
the other it's just that movie studios
tend to approach these comic book
adaptations in similar ways especially
when most of them are just trying to
make movies to sell toys there's really
only a couple ways to skin that cat
anyway more on that later but now it
looks like dr. Stone's mother box is
still in its original form and it's
opening up his world to spooky spooky
parademons and I'm guessing this is
taking place after the injury Victor
suffers that leads to his becoming
cyborg which is why all of his football
trophies are boxed up in the shot also
you gotta love the casting here with Joe
Morton as dr. stone a lot of you have
noticed that he also played doctor miles
Dyson from t2 judgement day like this
guy is perfect at playing scientists
whose research opens up the world to
these apocalyptic disasters scientists
when will they learn right alright
moving on
Arthur curry Aquaman Sonam organic and
biomechatronics body parts the cyborg
you should probably move okay so here we
saw more shots of Aquaman doing his
thing rescuing the stranded fishermen on
a rock and putting this bottle of booze
on his tab the same bottle that we saw
him chugging in the first trailer you
know I just hope he recycles it he don't
want your seahorse friends to get their
head Scott Nate Aquaman and as far as
his portrayal goes I feel like Jason
Momoa is combining a few different
superhero performances that I really
like there's definitely some Hugh
Jackman Wolverine in there he's the
angry loner and Bars who acts like he
doesn't care but totally does but then
also kind of Drax from the guardians of
the galaxy movies like the big guy a few
words who turns out to be just a big kid
in battle but really as much of a scene
stealer
Aquaman was in this trailer I was also
interested to finally see cyborg in
action like we barely saw any of them in
the last trailer and these renders look
a lot more detailed though I got to say
still maybe a little too CGI heavy but I
did appreciate that his torso and his
limbs look a bit thinner which makes
sense because his biomech tronic parts
are really just replacing missing body
parts and don't need to be as fleshed
out which I really like because if they
were too bulky it can kind of look like
a guy wearing a cyborg suit it should be
kind of lame whereas this seems a bit
more like how cyborg would really look
and check out this shot where he saves
the cop from this firey tank flipping
over on him now based on these
surroundings of the background of the
shot and that cop car it looks like this
could be taking place in that metropolis
city center so at least some of the
action in this movie will take us back
to Metropolis and I love cyborgs line
here you should probably move and I feel
like this cop might have said that to
Victor moments earlier and now cyborgs
turning the table on him all right
moving on Barry Allen
whoever you're looking for it's not me
is it Batman okay so we saw a lot of
this stuff with Barry Allen the flash in
the first trailer and she's definitely
check out our breakdown for that because
we dug deep into how fast the flash can
move based on the speed of the Batarang
as well as all the stuff in the
background including this screen with an
episode of Rick and Morty plane and we
get to see more of the Flash's super
speed and speed force which takes the
form of Blue Lightning probably to
differentiate from the CW series and
notice how the speed force grows
depending on how much Barry is exerting
himself with just a few bolts in Barry's
home when he's reaching out to grab the
Batarang but a full trail of energy as
the Jets across the landscape now
question here where does this take place
it sounds like part of Justice League
will take place on Stryker Island the
abandoned Island in the bay between
Gotham and metropolis where they fought
doomsday and I would say this scorched
earth looks a bit similar to that but
then look at those mountains in the
background
this is somewhere totally different it
also shows up as background and a few
other shots in this trailer and to me it
kind of looks like the ruins of a city
after a nuclear disaster like Chernobyl
or Oshima and other shots of this place
include these otherworldly formations
like this could be another planet or
earth after some terraforming is
underway like I'm thinking that maybe
dark side is terraforming earth into
apocalypse similar to how Zod tried to
do with Krypton in Man of Steel also it
could be that apocalyptic city that we
saw in the nightmare sequence that
Batman vs. Superman I don't know we'll
see and I love how right after Barry
realizes that Bruce is his favorite
superhero the trailer cuts to this super
Schneider II fanboy shot of Batman
swinging through a hail of parademon
fire and I gotta say just like the last
batfleck movie I'm really diggin the
fluidity of Batman's movements with this
dive and roll flowing right into him
flinging some kind of disabler on a para
demon it reminds me a lot of that smooth
motion of the warehouse fight a Batman
vs Superman and like then I feel like
this is inspired by the look in the
combat style of the Arkham games alright
moving on
he's in the Age of Heroes
a stew
okay so in this section over shots of
the Justice League lineup diana says
this they said the Age of Heroes would
never come again this is the first of
two subtle hints pointing towards the
backstory of this whole DC movie
universe and before I get into this
whole Age of Heroes reference I want to
talk real quick about our friends for
movement who sponsored this video so
movement makes really stylish and really
affordable watches which is really
useful for someone like me because
apparently people care about what you
look like when you're on YouTube so here
it is this is one of their watches and
there are a ton of options online and
you can order one at MVM T watches comm
slash new rockstars and get $15 off of
our code new rock stars
hey they also do sunglasses oh look at
me I'm James Bond but again if you want
an awesome watch for $15 off just go to
mV mt comm slash new rockstars and use
our code new rock stars okay back to
Diana's Age of Heroes line now you may
recognize Age of Heroes as a term from
The Game of Thrones backstory and a
brief limited series from the Marvel
Comics but I think Diana's meaning it
more generally here back to a time when
heroes stood together to defend earth
and she's most likely referring to her
Age of Heroes back in the days when the
Amazons and lanterns and men joined
forces to defeat Darkseid's forces but
it's possible that she's referring to a
more recent Age of Heroes because we
know that this version of Batman used to
work alongside partners as well but more
on that later and I really liked all the
shots of each of the Justice League
especially Aquaman using his Trident to
make some parademon kebab and you may
have recognized this music as a hard
rock cover of The Beatles come together
and even though I might have preferred
the original Beatles version I like of
this trailer uses this late 60s song
about people with conflicting ideologies
teaming up just like the Justice League
is doing it same time not to be too
negative about this trailer because I
really liked it but I could have done
without the justice for all title like I
get that the u.s. a marketing approach
is a common appeal and hey it has the
word justice in it however when you
think about it justice for all are the
final words of the Pledge of Allegiance
right and not all pledge started during
the Cold War so that people would swear
their loyalty to America
and against communism which isn't at all
what the Beatles were really preaching
we've come together so really this
justice for all is just kind of a
nonsensical addition that I'm guessing
the marketing people didn't really want
us to think about but then check out
this shot of one woman as she takes down
these guys in suits now this is really
the only time in the trailer that anyone
in the Justice League has taken down
human enemies not parademons so who are
these guys well check out those black
gloves they could be some high-level
thieves and maybe this is just an early
mission with one woman boiling a bank
robbery or something we also get this
shot of cyborg flying and I hate to
compare but come on look at the ways
helmet crawls over his face it's gotta
be inspired by you know old tin can
metal head what's his name again but
really I just love the photography as
cyborg shoots through the clouds at the
moon it has this dreamlike
escapist quality kind of like the
memorable shots from ET or Aladdin this
also feels like the kind of melodramatic
move past versions the Superman would
pull rising above it all trying to get
away from his grounded problems like why
can't I save everyone anyway let's move
on what are your superpowers again I'm
rich
watch shark so in this section we get
another look at the flash from the first
trailer and now we see he's fighting a
parademon using the momentum from his
super speed to blast him through a wall
and yeah it's super great to hear Bruce
say that his superpowers are that he's
rich basically echoing the thought that
we've all had about the Batman at some
point like sure world's greatest
detective multi skilled fighter master
illusionist yeah yeah yeah I'm with you
but yeah it's nice to see Bruce
acknowledge that money helps and to be
honest I'm really liking the bat Flex
comedic timing in this footage like he
seems way less moody than he was a
Batman versus Superman but also not too
wisecrack he like spider-man or Deadpool
would be athletic performance reminds me
more of the tone of like Kevin Conroy
Batman from the animated series like he
avoids chitchat and he makes the most of
his few words I'll be able to go into
your brain even if you're wide awake my
brains not a nice place to be we also
get our first look at the night crawler
in action the night crawler is a new
tank like Batmobile that can climb
services and you can see that extendable
arm that he uses to pierce surfaces to
get a hold kind of like an ice axe used
by mountain climbers and I love how the
cockpit allows for a different seating
position for Batman for when the crawler
goes vertical kind of like the gunner
position and the tumbler from Batman
Begins and if you look closely this
whole location is the same shaft that we
saw all of them walking into at the end
of the first trailer and I'm guessing
that this could be the parademon nest
that people described from set visits
may be part of the tunnels underneath
Stryker Island and it could just be me
but when Affleck says my turn and
returns fire on the parademons it seems
like he's channeling his past role in
Pearl Harbor just a little bit
shooting baggage whoo I forgot about
that accent okay let's move on
okay so a few more interesting shots in
this section first there's a shot of
Victor stone in this football days and
the last trailer we saw him in is GCU
letterman jacket so I'm guessing that
we're gonna see a priest cyborg flash
back before he got his new body we also
get this finished shot of Wonder Woman
slamming her gauntlet on her shield
which we saw in behind-the-scenes
footage with a green screen there's
another shot of the flash from inside
his Speed Force as the swing
side-to-side and this kind of reminds me
of the chase scene in the movie The
Incredibles with - and that character
was obviously inspired by the flash
there's also this quick shot of Lois
Lane suggesting that even though
Superman doesn't appear anywhere in his
trailer his presence will still be felt
throughout Justice League on an
emotional level and yeah he'll probably
into playing somewhere on the story more
than just his absence bringing all them
together
there's also Aquaman using his trident
to control this raging water kind of
like Moses and the Ten Commandments or
Jean Grey at the end of X - and judging
from the walls of this place this could
be the inside the flying fox which is
kind of like Bruce's base of command
aircraft that contains the Batmobile own
stuff you see him and Diana in in the
line but this location kind of looks a
bit more like that tunnel shaft location
as it gets flooded and Aquaman is buying
time for the rest of the team and before
I move on we get this quick shot of Mira
in Atlantis flanked by two Atlantean
bodyguards Mira is Aquaman's wife and
queen of Atlantis and she's played here
by Amber Heard alright let's move on
[Music]
shall we so in this section we get these
quick shots of Barry Allen with his
father played by Billy Crudup who
previously worked with Zack Snyder in
the watchman he played dr. Manhattan and
actually this same scene with Barry
talking to him from behind prison glass
was depicted in the CW series and that
show Henry Allen was falsely accused of
murdering Barry's mother when the real
culprit was reverse-flash now I'm not
sure if the movie is gonna go that deep
into Barry's backstory or if the
reverse-flash will be part of this movie
it may just be a nod to that or setting
up a solo film okay back to these
massive battlefield shots showing us
thousands of parademons fighting the
Amazons so it looks like we're actually
gonna see some of this ancient war from
dark sides first invasion attempt maybe
as a prologue for this whole movie and I
love that Schneider shot it with this
epic sense of scale similar to Mordor in
the Lord of the Rings films and if you
look closely at these shots there's
actually some similarities to the
nightmare sequence in Batman vs Superman
the terrain is covered in these massive
markings similar to the Darkseid Omega
symbol and in the background you can see
the same fiery column suggesting that
Darkseid was indeed trying to use terror
formation in this ancient battle okay
let's move on to this final section
it's good to see you playing well with
others again just like a bat I dig it
may be temporary
okay so yeah obviously lots of great
stuff here first we see JK Simmons
taking over as Jim Gordon and he says
the most intriguing line in this trailer
it's good to see you playing well with
others again so along with that Age of
Heroes line playing well with others
again sets up a super interesting
backstory for Batman
because Gordon is referring to the fact
that Batman used to work with partners
namely Robin Jason Todd and Nightwing
Dick Grayson
remember in Batman vs Superman we saw
how Bruce Keith's Robins destroyed and
disfigured suit in the Batcave implying
that Robin was killed by Joker kind of
like in the comic definitely also there
was that little easter egg in Suicide
Squad on Harley Quinn's bio where she
was listed as an accomplice to murder of
Robin suggesting that she and Joker
murdered him together in this movie
universe timeline and this line from
Gordon suggests that we might see a
flashback to that moment we also know
that Warner Brothers is planning on a
Nightwing solo film either way it sounds
like a big focus of Justice League will
be Batman struggle to work with partners
and deal with that guilt it's also great
to see Aquaman in his full Atlantean
getup finally making fun of someone else
in the Justice League just like a bad a
diggin and notice how Bruce is kind of
smirking here because he knows that this
is a callback to that moment that ended
the last trailer where he said this
Aquaman
and yeah we all love this shot of
Aquaman's surfing on the Batmobile
showing he's just as much of a badass on
land and air has he is on sea but why do
we love this shot so much now I have a
theory that this particular shot with
that man and Aquaman together and others
like it are what drive all of these
superhero movies like notice how most of
the iconic moments from all the films in
the genre include multiple superheroes
sharing the screen either through
teamwork or infighting so that their
abilities complement each other in
interesting ways
for example Ironman using caps shield to
reflect the beam in the Avengers and
it's Superman Batman and Wonder Woman
each using their abilities to take down
doomsday Thor hidden cap shield to
create a shockwave an age of Ultron
spider-man snatching cap shield and
Civil War Colossus tossing Wolverine in
the last stand
ant-man writing hawkeye's arrow and
jumping into Iron Man's armor and now
Aquabat so why do we love these images
so much because boy
all of these are the same kinds of
fantasy scenarios we would create with
our action figures as kids like sure
Batman and Wolverine can be best friends
and they drive in a Ninja Turtles Pizza
car and you better believe that DC and
Marvel depend on these visuals in
particular driving kids and their
parents and lonely man children out to
stores all over the world to spend
billions of dollars on small plastic
versions of these characters and various
things that look like that it's the
whole reason the studio's are shelling
out these huge budgets for these movies
and why the films are sometimes
criticized for being more focused on
spectacle than they are on story and
character because let's face it story
and character are great but they don't
really move much anyway industry
citizens on the side I'm absolutely
going to spend my money seeing Justice
League because I'm a sheep this movie
looks great from the trailers of course
I felt the same way about the trailers
of Suicide Squad and Batman vs Superman
and Man of Steel but maybe this time
Zack Snyder will get it right right okay
let me know what you think in the
comments and check out our breakdown of
the first Justice League trailer from
Comic Con last year and my breakdowns of
the Wonder Woman trailers which looks
like it's gonna play a big role in
setting up the events of Justice League
thanks for watching and if you liked
this video please hit like and subscribe
to new rock stars also please share this
video and if you really like new rock
stars you can contribute to us on
patreon thank you so much to all of our
current patrons you guys are the best
especially reverends andrea rev your
name is as amazing as your generosity
you can hit me up on twitter at EA boss
with any thoughts or theories you have
on Justice League or follow new rock
stars on Twitter at new rockstars for
updates on our videos alright thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
[Music]